dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér
this paper is from the google deepmind
guides and is about teaching neural
networks to be capable of relational
reasoning this means that we can present
the algorithm with an image and ask it
relatively complex relational questions
for instance if we show it this image
and ask what is the color of the object
that is closest to the blue object it
would answer red this is a particularly
difficult problem because all the
algorithm has access to is a bunch of
pixels in computer code it is near
impossible to mathematically express
that in an image something is below or
next to something else
especially in three-dimensional scenes
beyond the list of colors this requires
a cognitive understanding of the
entirety of the image this is something
that we humans are amazingly good at but
computer algorithms are dreadful for
this type of work and this work almost
feels like teaching common-sense to a
learning algorithm this is accomplished
by augmenting an already existing neural
network with a relational network module
this is implemented on top of a
recurrent neural network that we call
long short term memory or lsdm that is
able to process sequences of information
for instance an input sentence the more
seasoned fellow scholars know that we
have talked about LSD ms in earlier
episodes and of course as always the
video description contains these
episodes for your enjoyment make sure to
have a look you'll love it as you can
see in this result this relational
reasoning also works for
three-dimensional scenes as well the
aggregated results in the paper show
that this method is not only leaps and
bounds beyond the capabilities of
already existing algorithms but and now
hold on to your papers in many cases it
also shows superhuman performance I
loved seeing these charts in machine
learning papers where several learning
algorithms and humans are benchmarked on
the same tasks this paper was barely
published and there is already a first
unofficial public implementation and two
research papers have
they referenced it this is such a great
testament to the incredible pace of
machine learning research these days to
say that it is competitive would be a
huge understatement achieving high
quality results in relational reasoning
is an important cornerstone for
achieving general intelligence and even
though there is still much much more to
do today is one of those days when we
can feel that we are a part of the
future
the failure cases are also reported in
the paper and are definitely worthy of
your time and attention when I ask for
permissions to cover this paper in the
series all three scientists from deep
mind happily answered yes within 30
minutes that's unbelievable
thanks guys also some of these questions
sound like ones that we would get in the
easier part of an IQ test I wouldn't be
very surprised to see a learning
algorithm complete a full IQ test with
flying colors in the near future if you
enjoyed this episode and you feel that
eight of these videos a month is worth a
dollar please consider supporting us on
patreon this way we can make better
videos for your enjoyment we have
recently reached a new milestone which
means that part of these funds will be
used to empower research projects
details are available in the video
description thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time
[Music]